you were a very successful comedian
you're very funny comedian and then you
write a wedding book why why the wedding
book um I wrote the wedding book because
when I got engaged I felt like all of
the publications out there for new
brides we're just very focused on
pushing goods and services really
selling the fantasy and the fantasy is
super fun I fully endorsed the fantasy
but it also was like there needs to be a
proper dose of reality wedding planning
is really stressful and really hard and
my now husband died were like fighting
all the time and I'm like no one's
talking about this and also no one's
being funny about it right so it felt
like there was a real hole in the
bookshelf that I was intending on
filling and yeah I also was like you
know there's so much stress in the
wedding planning process I want to take
that stress and then refocus it on to
other things like are you marrying the
right guy you know just keeping it real
yeah and you were marrying the right guy
hope yeah okay good cuz we're divorced
now and we're to give advice now there's
a big thing now where people have
wedding hashtags
yeah is that something that you were
into I was um what I've noticed on
Instagram is people try to take their
last name and make a pun out of it so
like if my last name was Evans would be
like thank Evans I found her like Evans
to Betsy or whatever but not all last
names lend themselves to punning my
husband's last name is black and I was
like ah once I go black like I don't
know
I think that works perfectly yeah like
we'll just do Jam dan 2016 check it out
feel free to to scroll that when you're
done we're we're people when you made
the announcement that the two people to
your friends that you were getting
married were they excited were they
happy for you people are so excited you
people are so excited for you to the
point where you're like oh you know I
didn't earn this right like I just
orchestrated it like one girl was like
oh my god Jamie how did you know how did
you know he was the one I was like oh
when I was 32 and not married first
grader like how did you know you wanted
on my little pony it's like uh when
Britney Ashley Jennifer and Jennifer's
friend got the horse isn't that great
you still want to be the only [ __ ]
without something to brush I know it's
very brave to say how old I am out loud
on national television but I just want
to say that um you know you if you could
I think the problem is like people need
to lie about their age properly because
if I was like guys I'm 47 you'd be like
oh my god you look unbelievable I was
like I'm 23 you'd be like yes and that's
why I assumed you're on meth I just
thought you know we're all in the
business was it hard for you to choose I
remembered when I got married
my wife and I there was a lot of
discussion about where are we gonna have
this event and you know I was like I
would want it in a bowling alley and
know that didn't happen but with
choosing a location were difficult
actually choosing the location was great
we found this amazing outdoor botanical
garden and the big selling point for
this venue was that they had an aviary
that you walk through with all these
white peacocks in the cages and I was
like ooh spicy white peacocks I'm in
then a month before the wedding I just
had a feeling that we needed to go look
at the venue one more time just had a
hunch so I'm walking through the aviary
and all of the cages are now empty with
like feather debris like newly empty
like it was a crime scene like
sweetie bird was like just eaten in the
swing was still going just like the one
lone feather dripping down and yeah it
looked like a crime scene and then there
was one cage that did still have birds
in it but they were not like peacocks
they were not doves they were no wedding
bird
they were just pigeons walk the gawking
rats of the sky disgust Oh birds and try
to write the groundskeeper an email and
he wrote me back defending it he's like
Jamie these aren't just any pigeons ok
these are rare Siberian McCaughey pigeon
I was like that is not a thing there is
no such thing as a class-d pigeon like
that's like going to the gynecologist
and they're like okay you do have an STD
but it's a one of the rare one one of
the really cool exotic STD yeah people
have gonorrhea but you're keeping it
alive
you